[Music]
[Applause]
David Pollock always good form somehow a
smooth Segway college game day ESPN
college football analyst and uh they
have the big game in Columbus the
Rivalry week the game Ohio State in
Michigan and that'll be coming up game
day 9 A.M till noon on Saturday on the
mothership and ESPN app if you didn't go
to Georgia where were you going
I would have gone to uh Clemson or Ohio
State those are probably my next two
that I would have gone to what was the
recruiting stuff you got a good
recruiting story
well Dan I wasn't really that highly
recruited uh was it like some of these
well wait a minute clinician and Ohio
State and Georgia
well I had I think I had four or five
offers
um coming out of high school but Clemson
was the only School actually that
recruited me on defense Ohio State
Georgia recruited me on offense
um but uh I I got a good recruiting
story for Ohio State dude I'm from the
south Dan you know that I'm from Georgia
lived in Georgia my whole life I went on
a recruiting trip to Ohio State and I
flew up there during the season to go
watch a game and I got off the plane and
there was like six inches of snow and I
was like what and Sam heck is that Mom
like absolutely no deal breaker
um absolutely I'm out right now and then
guess what you know five years later or
four years later I'm drafted by the
Cincinnati Bengals
oh it's amazing
uh maybe you shouldn't have flown up if
you didn't fly up to no if you had gone
up in September you might have gone God
this is beautiful the foliage
everything's great you know
never forget damn with the Bengals man
I'll never forget everybody was
complaining about camping like it's so
hot I'm like what this is this is Spring
ball in Georgia like this like and you
know when the weather changes especially
you know us the bigger guys like the
weather changes you know your energy
level goes up but you can run all day
your lungs feel so good and I was like
this is amazing but yeah first time I
ever got on an airplane was my my flight
my official visit to Ohio State do you
get accused of preferential treatment
for Georgia like Kirk Herbstreit maybe
with Ohio State
oh 100 and there's no like it's funny to
watch your timelines on social media
Because by the way I love it I love the
hatred on social media like I I
absolutely think it's comical I think
it's funny I I think it's awesome
um but if I pick Georgia you know I got
a bunch of a segment of people that
you're a homer blah blah blah and then
if I pick against Georgia I'm Benedict
Arnold and I've actually gotten in my
wife several years ago gotten an
altercation this was like five years ago
in my living room my wife is the most
passive person ever one of my friend's
wives are like what's wrong with you you
played at Georgia how could you pick
against Georgia they made you what you
are blah blah blah and it was like
Georgia fans every time I pick against
them they get upset I'm like listen
here's when I grew up in the business I
watched a couple of guys and I'll never
forget watching Lou Holtz and he coached
at South Carolina and he coached at
Arkansas and he coached at Notre Dame
and every time he talked about South
Carolina Arkansas and Notre Dame he
picked him and he he loves them and
obviously I get it but I remember those
moments when I was growing up and
broadcasting I'm like I'm gonna make
sure I don't do that I'm gonna make sure
I pick the best team who I think is
going to win and let the chips fall
where they may and whether Dan it
doesn't matter what we do you know how
this works if you pick somebody you
could say the nicest thing in the
history of the world about the other
school and pick them as soon as you pick
them you think their team's trash and
they're going to say something about it
and they're going to hit you up and and
it really doesn't matter
what happened with your wife and you
know the the guest who came over with
almost get ugly no I wish man I wish my
wife could bring them things my wife's
my wife's like five eight a buck 25 she
ain't got she would get stomped out but
she she was just like seriously why do
you feel that way and the other lady
would pushing back it was a nice little
almost a cat fight in December in the in
the Pollock living room
all right what stood out last night what
should we be keeping an eye on with
these rankings and and which team or
teams
I think um I think USC obviously isn't
isn't a huge position to to do something
good when you've got Notre Dame on the
schedule you just beat a ranked UCLA the
Pac-12 good chance would be Oregon next
week to get another feather in your cap
so I think USC is that team if somebody
slips up who could be lurking the
interesting thing to me is it depends
who slips up and it depends how much
space we have between everybody else
because if TCU loses a close one this
week and then wins the Big 12 are they
still in if Ohio State loses to Michigan
are they still above USC I mean I think
USC is going to be that team that
everybody's looking at like please go
ahead and lose the Notre Dame so we make
sure that we have a chance because I I
don't think Michigan with their
non-conference schedule and the way they
haven't been necessarily as explosive
offensively that there is a team that's
going to go oh yeah they lost close to
Ohio state they're in the dance Colorado
state Hawaii you Yukon when yukon's your
best at a conference game and it's in
its football season you got a problem
yeah I mean so so they're at a
conference schedule I think that hurt
them but USC is definitely the team that
you look at that says has a chance to
rise and then growth opportunity what do
you think happens in the Ohio State
Michigan game
I tell you what the more physical team
wins this game that is just you look at
whoever runs the ball the best whoever's
the most physical like I talked about
the weather is cold to me what I've seen
so far from Michigan I think Michigan is
the more physical team Ohio State I'm
still learning about them
um offensively they don't they don't
push enough guys around and create
enough space and I think Michigan's
d-line I think it's going to be a low
scoring game but remember and I'll never
forget I still will say this till I till
I die the hardest thing in college
football is to go on the road and win in
tough atmospheres so is Michigan
explosive enough Ohio state has the
Revenge Factor as well but I think
Michigan to me what I've seen so far has
been the more physical team yeah they
got a lot of injuries there uh yeah you
know and going into Ohio State but but
it's almost like Ohio State wanted to be
more like an um
an SEC team that they didn't want the
three yards in a cloud of dust that they
wanted it wide open and and made a
concerted effort Michigan is still sort
of that three yards in a cloud of dust
that's that's Harbaugh's personality and
now Ryan day they want it it's like when
uh kiffin got to Alabama with Saban
help me help me open it up that's how
we're going to get recruits that's how
we're going to keep up with everybody
else there but you think Ohio State
having
a wide open offense but not that
physicality we'll keep Michigan in this
game well and here's the thing that that
I haven't heard enough people talk about
like CJ Stroud is a machine Dan like I
could take you through so many of his
clips and I could go watch this watch
his touchdown pass to ambuka in the
fourth quarter of Penn State and you
talk about Rhythm and timing the dude is
incredible like when the structure of
the offense and everything is clean CJ
Stroud's the best quarterback in the
college football when it's not and
there's a little bit of something off
whether it be a pass rush the creativity
he doesn't have that Bryce young
creativity where he can play off script
and now put the ball out sidearm he
doesn't run the football really really
good so if the interior the weakness of
Ohio State's offensive line is guard
Center guard if those guys can make CJ
Stroud a little bit uncomfortable and
make him move his feet which I think
they'll be able to a little bit then
then he becomes he goes from the best
quarterback to an average Quarterback so
I think I think Ohio States called their
game plan this whole year Dan with with
Michigan in mind at the end of the
season they usually they usually throw
the football all over the yard super
aggressive hyper aggressive I think
they've ran the ball more this year at a
higher clip and into heavier boxes
because they know against Michigan at
the end of the year when physicality
matters the most when it's cold as crap
and receivers don't catch the football
as well quarterbacks don't vote as well
we have to be ready for that moment
David Pollock from the mothership ESPN
college football analyst and game day
will be in Columbus they start at 9 00
a.m go to noon on ESPN I mentioned this
to Joel clatt the other day if you're
Drake May
can't go to the NFL
you're at North Carolina
what if he went out on the open market
what would he be worth on the open what
if Drake May said to Ohio State CJ
Stroud is going to the pros
I'd like to help you
could you call your boosters here
the price starts at 10 million dollars
wow I haven't heard anybody say that by
the way I love
I love what you're saying because I'll
say this man like four weeks ago we
talked about it on game day and and I
was like dude this dude is the best in
college football and and everybody kind
of looked at me a little bit like this
I'm like he does more things better than
everybody like he's six five he's 220 he
throws into Tight Windows he throws
Under Pressure he scrambles to get time
he can throw he can he spreads it around
the multiple receivers that's a that's
an amazing a point and here's what I
would do Dan if he did that and I was at
all these big time schools
hey which one of my boosters or a
billionaire which one of them bro I need
I need I need 10 million dollars I'm
going to get you the best quarterback in
college football like can you make that
happen I I I think it's an absolute it
would be an absolute no-brainer yeah but
this happened with Caleb Williams when
he left Oklahoma he was the open market
who wants to give me the most and USC
ponied up to bring in Caleb Williams
well and think about Quinn hears
the number one player in the country in
high school you know three years ago
gets a boatload of money from Ohio State
and then Dan guess what free agent
Market again and then goes to Texas and
gets a boatload of money like to me that
would be the wave of the future if I'm
these I'm a business guy like hey at a
high school take all the money you can
take highest offer after a year you can
take another high offer and go to
somewhere else so I tell you I had to
hate to be the coaches nowadays having
to navigate this crap but I think Drake
May is is unreal and he can do things
that
um that only Drake may can do and and he
would definitely claim whatever I think
he could write a blank Tennessee's
quarterback like got eight million I
think something like that like if if he
got eight million then Drake May is
worth at least 10.
is Lane kiffin just goofing around here
I don't know but how awesome is it I
mean how amazing is it but how would you
feel if he takes the Auburn job after
what he's been doing on social media I
think he's going to I think yeah oh you
do okay I do I think he's going to but I
think what he said specifically was I
haven't taken the Auburn job yet I'm not
going to step down and take the Auburn
job I I don't know that he said I'm not
taking the Auburn job period I'm not in
the mix yeah that's what I'm waiting for
I just want him to he you know when you
hear the report like he told his team
that he had not accepted the Auburn job
or you know and I went did he say I'm
not going to leave Ole Miss that's what
I want to know it's semantics is all
this is but I if you said on Saturday is
Lane kiffin in Auburn I would not be
surprised
I wouldn't either and I think for Auburn
it'd be a really good hire Auburn did
something last time they went outside of
the league and got Brian harson I don't
think Auburn's doing that again like
Auburn's not going to go outside of the
league and have the growing pains and
then the boosters be upset but but it's
interesting Auburn is the most one of
the most polarizing jobs in all of
college football they've got ridiculous
fans ridiculous resources unbelievable
Stadium campus they have every
ridiculous access to recruits they have
this is the best job that's on the
market and it's not close like they have
they've won national championships with
Gene chizik like they they've done that
like they they as a team that can win
win win and win big if you can get the
right guy Nick Saban obviously getting a
little bit older Lane kiffin I mean
imagine the shots he'd be taking it
would be it would be gorgeous but if I
said you could have Dion or Lane kiffin
at Auburn
and Dion wants the job yeah Dion
definitely wants that job I tell you
what I think Dion's a problem for people
I think I think Dion we we went to uh we
went there we got to go to Jackson it
was awesome that we got to go there and
for game day and let me tell you
something if you spend any time around
Dion like he he gonna get the moment
like you think about recruiting the
moments like brocktown's gonna walk in
there and smooth everybody like he's got
he's got such a you know big smile a big
person out but here's the thing to know
about Dion too Dion's also got
competitive toughness Dion doesn't put
up with crap like they're gonna look the
same on the practice field you know
they're going to dress the same you're
gonna show up and you're gonna practice
like Dion Dion got one of the best
recruits in the country last year with
Travis Hunter the top recruit in the
country to come to him and play FBC HBCU
like are you kidding like imagine what
he could do at a place like Auburn with
that brand and those resources
are those your kids behind you over your
right shoulder yeah they just walked in
yeah you'd be dad
close to Columbus and dress warm okay
hey you know what after Montana dancing
my toes are still frozen wait hey Dan
hold on herb Street got his feet
massaged on
yeah on on the set
you know I think as a teammate you know
I'm required to be a good team man I
have no comment Dan okay I mean I don't
know I know there's videos and all that
stuff but he's from Ohio he's the
toughest dude on set by far like he has
his AC unit on when it's 30 degrees I
mean he usually but negative five was a
different animal Dan all right Dan I got
a question for you okay I got a question
for you bro how was your how is your
form talk about Prince's form it's solid
how's yours it's great
great not just good it's great yeah okay
we're going to put that to the test one
day well I mean you want to shoot free
throws here I I'll make I'll make seven
or eight out of ten with my eyes that's
that's no it's pretty solid with my eyes
closed
I don't I'm not buying that I'm gonna
need video Polly would you confirm yeah
we tried it David and uh Dan usually
goes about nine for ten from the free
throw line and but we did it eyes closed
he went seven for seven for ten
confirmed yeah how many years ago was
this is less than six months ago
oh wow yeah you got to know your
opponent David mad mad props I couldn't
do that yeah if you would like to
apologize I I formally I formally humbly
I'll accept it
would you would you would you massage my
feet now
[Laughter]
safe travels to Columbus there buddy I
see you brother all right that's David
Pollock
see they I mean don't question it I mean
stuff to the king yeah you wouldn't do
that in person no he would not you know
that disappointed